اهلا بكم نفى ايه الله هاشمي رفسنجاني عدم
نيته الترشح لرئاسه مجلس خبراء القياده في
ايران مؤكدا انه معني بهذا المنصب المفصلي
في بنيه النظام الايراني في حال تقدم
لشغله من وصفهم بغير الاكفا نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
ما هي الخلفيات والاعتبارات التي حكمت
الموقف الذي اعلنه رفسنجاني
والى اين يمكن ان تؤول مختلف الرهانات
المتعلقه بمنصب رئاسه مجلس خبراء القياده
في النظام الايراني
لن في عدم النيه في الترشح لرئاسه مجلس
الخبراء كرس اكبر هاشمي رفسنجاني صورته
كسياسي مخضرم وشخصيه من الصف الاول في
النظام الايراني واكبت كبرى تحولات ه
تحولات صنعتها جمله عوامل من اهمها صراع
صراع مزمل بين المحافظين والاصلاحيين
معسكر ان تطفو الخلافات بينهما بقوه كلما
مرت بموعد انتخابي او بمنصب المحور في
بنيه النظام في ايران
كان مجرد اعلانه عدم استبعاد الترشح
لرئاسه مجلس خبراء القياده في ايران وان
بشروط كفيلا ب فتح باب التوقعات
والتساؤلات على مصراعيه انه اكبر هاشمي
رفسنجاني الرئيس الايراني الاسبق والرئيس
الاسبق ايضا ل مجلس خبراء القياده الذي
شغل منصب القياده فيه بوفاه رئيسه الثالث
منذ الثوره الايرانيه ايه الله مهدوي كني
قبل ايام رفسنجاني احد ابرز الوجوه في
الساحه السياسيه الايرانيه اشترط لاحتمال
ترشحه لهذا المنصب الحساس ي ايرانيا ان
يرى في المترشحين غياب الكفاءه او ان
ترشحهم لا يخدم مصالح بلاد مجلس خبراء
القياده الذي يجري الجدل على كرسي رئاسته
يطلع وفق الدستور الايراني بمهام بالغه
الاهميه منها انتخاب المرشد الاعلى للثوره
وخلعه اذا ثبت عجزه او فقد اهليته للمنصب
كما يقوم ب مراقبه ورصد اداء المرشد على
كل المستويات ويقدم تقريرا سريا نصف سنويا
بهذا الشان يرفع الى جهات رسميه غير معلنه
مهام يرى كثير من مراقبي المشهد السياسي
الايراني انها ستكتسب بلا ريب اهميه قصوى
في استحقاقات يستبعد ان تخلو من ها
السنوات الثماني القادمه مده ولايه المجلس
الدستوريه وهو عامل اضافي يكسب الصراع على
رئاسه المجلس في هذه المره اهميه قصوى
ورغم ان شخصيه رفسنجاني تحظى بقبول واسع
من تيار المحافظين والاصلاحيين على السواء
الا ان فكره ترشحه لرئاسه مجلس الخبراء قد
لا تحظى بذات القدر من التوافق براي
كثيرين بان المجلس لا يوجد به اصلاحيون
اسمك رفسنجاني لو ترشح المنصب له وهو
احتمال ان تحقق سيقوي حظوظ تيار الاصلاح
على الصعيد الخارجي الذي تلعب فيه السياسه
الايرانيه على اكثر من ساحه يرى باحثون
مختصون في السياسه الايرانيه ان عوده
رفسنجاني المحتمله لرئاسه مجلس خبراء
القياده قد تبعث برسائل ذات مغزى في اكثر
من اتجاه
فالرجل المتصف بقدر لا باس به من
البراغماتيه السياسيه قلت سابقا خطوات نزع
فتيل ازمات مع الجوار الخليجي والسعودي
تحديدا كما انه كان اول من جهر من داخل
نظام الثوره الايرانيه بضروره غلق ملف
العداء مع الولايات المتحده ميراث قد
يصطدم باجندات يمينيه داخليه يحملها خصوما
قويه ل رفسنجاني من قبيل قيادات الحرس
الثوري الايراني ما يبقى ابواب تجدد
الصراع بين تياري المحافظين والاصلاحيين
مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات
معنا في هذه الحلقه من طهران الدكتور محمد
مهدي شريعه مدار الاكاديمي والخبير في
العلاقات الدوليه وهنا في الاستوديو فات
ماديه الباحثه في الشان الايراني ب مركز
الجزيره للدراسات اهلا بضيفينا نبدا
بالدكتور سريعه مدار في في طهران لو تشرح
لنا اكثر هذا الموقف الذي اعلنه
رفسنجاني في اي سياق يمكن وضعه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بعد ان اعلن احد
اعضاء مجلس الخبراء مجلس خبراء القياده اه
كيفيه انتخاب الرئيس القادم لهذا المجلس
اه وعندما سئل بانه هل من المتوقع ان
يترشح الشيخ هاشمي رفسنجاني للرئاسه مره
ثانيه اجاب بان الشيخ رفسنجاني اكد في بعض
اجتماعات المجلس بانه لم يترشح على ضوء او
بعد هذا التصريح جاء تصريح الشيخ هاشمي
رفسنجاني بانه اذا لم يجد من اه فيه
الاهليه الكافيه لرئاسه هذا المجلس سيترشح
هذا هو كان تصريح الشيخ هاشمي رفسنجاني
بالضبط او برايك لماذا اضاف اذا لم يتقدم
له اهليه
اه لانه يرى بان بانه اذا كان اه ال
المتقدمين لرئاسه او المترشحون الى اسس
مجلس لهم الاهليه الكافيه ل اه اه
استلام هذا المنصب فلا داعي لان يترشح مره
اخرى وهذا هو ما حصل في الماضي بينما ترشح
الشيخ مهدي المرحوم الشيخ مهدوي كني
للرئاسه انسحب الشيخ هاشمي رفسنجاني
لصالحه لانه كان يرى فيه الرجل الكفء
لرئاسه هذا المجلس ذلك حتى طبعا
اعتدنا في ايران على ان لا يكون هذا
المجلس مجلس خبراء القياده وهو يضم اكثر
من ثمانين شخصا من كبار العلماء في ايران
اه لا يشهد اه التنافسات السياسيه الحزبيه
والفئويه
اه وانما مثلا في الدورات الثلاث الاولى
كان الشيخ مشكيني المرحوم الشيخ المشكله
هو رئيس المجلس وايضا كان الشيخ هاشمي
نائبا للرئيس بعده جاء الشيخ هاشمي
رفسنجاني ثم الشيخ مهدوي كني لذلك هذا
المجلس
من طبيعته انه انه لا يحتمل التنافس
السياسي اتصور بان موقف الشيخ هاشمي
رفسنجاني كان نابعا من ذلك الا اذا كان
المترشح حمل رايه غير كفوء لاستلام هذا
المنصب ومع ذلك سيدي هناك على ما يبدو نوع
من التنافس لان هناك مرشح اخر هو ايه الله
هاشمي شهر ودي واه كلام رفسنجاني يمكن ان
يفهم على انه نعم ويمكن ان يفهم يفهم على
انه لا كيف فهمتني ولا يمكن ان نسقط
التنافس السياسي من اه الترشح ترشح
شادي اه يعني اه اليوم تحديدا كان هناك
لقاء مع احمد خاتمي اه خطيب جمعه طهران
وقال ان اه هاشمي رفسنجاني لن يترشح لان
ال يعني هناك اصوات عديده ترشح هودي وتجد
فيه الصلاحيه لذلك هناك اسماء كثيره
الوضع نعم اه اه الترشح رفسنجاني لهذا
المنصب ياتي ضمن اه التنافس السياسي
القائم في ايران ولا يمكن اسقاطه على
الاطلاق حتى عندما يعني خرج رفسنجاني في
السابق من رئاسه المجلس او لم يترشح
للرئاسه المجلس وتركه ل اه مهدوي كني ايضا
كان ضمن التنافس السياسي القائم يعني كان
في فتره رفسنجاني تعرض فيها يعني لشيء ما
يشبه الاقصاء السياسي من الساحه السياسيه
الايرانيه والساحه السياسيه او
الاطراف السياسيه في ايران لم تكن تحتمل
ذلك ولذلك كان مهدوي كني اه يعني حلا وسطا
بين الاطراف السياسيه المتصارعه في ايران
عوده جاليه الان هي تاتي ضمن سياق عوده بس
الجاليه السياسيه القويه الى الساحه
السياسيه الايرانيه وخاصه اذا ما عرفنا ان
روحاني هو التلميذ النجيب او المخلص لتيار
رفسنجاني ولكن في هذه الحلقه يتحدث عن
اهليه ومن والاكفاء وغير الاكثر هل يمكن
ان نضع اه اه اه ايه الله هاشمي الشهر ودي
في في في خانه دون اخرى على الاقل من وجهه
نظر رفسنجاني برايك
هل تقصد خانه الكفاءه من عدم الكفاءه
الرجل الشهر ودي له اه تاريخ اه يعني اه
في الجمهوريه الاسلاميه وكان الرئيس
للسلطه القضائيه الرجل له اه يعني له حضور
قوي داخل المجلس له اه مؤيدين اه له
مؤيدين حتى من خارج المجلس من الطيف
السياسي ال الاصولي اه الرجل له علاقه
جيده مع الحرس الثوري له علاقه جيده مع
مرشد الثوره الاسلاميه وبالتالي مساله ال
الكفاءه احيانا قد تكون احد اوجه التنافس
السياسي والصراع السياسي في ايران اه اه
سيد اه
امريكا اشرت الى ان هذا المنصب لا يخضع
على التجاذبات السياسيه والتنافس السياسي
وهو ما اه اه اه تبدي عليه ملاحظات السيد
الصادق
هل تعتقد بان اهميه المنصب الان في ظل
الوضع السياسي الداخلي الحالي في ايران
ستجعل هذا المنصب شئنا ام ابينا اه محل
تنافس
نعم من دون شك ان الوضع السياسي في ايران
يترك اثاره على كل المؤسسات الدستوريه هذا
لا شك فيه ولكن ينبغي ان نعلم بانه بشكل
عام من مميزات المؤسسه الدينيه في لدى
الشيعه وخاصه في ايران وان علماء الدين
عاده لا يتاثرون في الاطر الحزبيه
والتنظيميه هذا اه ليس فقط في ايران
الشهيد الصدر رحمه الله هو الذي اسس حزب
الدعوه الاسلاميه في العراق لكنه فيما بعد
من علماء الدين من الانخراط فيه المؤسسات
الدينيه والحوزات العلميه وحتى التنظيمات
التي تضم علماء الدين هي عباره عن تجمعات
وجماعات وليس تنظيمات والحزبيه من هذا
المنطلق انا اقول بان هذه المؤسسه لا تخضع
الى التنافس والى التجاذبات السياسيه
التي اعتدنا عليه اه في اه اه يعني
التجاذبات الحزبيه في الدول الاخرى وايضا
في ايران اه انا اتصور لكن هذا لا يعني
بان الوضع السياسي لن يترك اثاره على مجلس
الخبراء كما انه في السابق ترك ذلك في
المره الماضيه حيث
الشيخ هاشمي رفسانجاني لصالح الشيخ مهدي
في الحقيقه كان ذلك بتاثير من الجو
السياسي في ايران لكن الكل كان يعتقد وحتى
المقربين من الشيخ هاشمي رفسنجاني كانوا
يعتقدون بانه لو كان يرشح نفسه كان له
الحق اه ربما ل اه اه ان يكون في هذا
المنصب اذا الموضوع هو موضوع اه يعني
ينبغي ان نفهم الاليه التي تحكم تجمعات
علماء الدين في ايران اه في هذا الموضوع
ولكن اه طالما ان السيد رفسنجاني يوسف
اجمالا بانه من الاصلاحيين سيده فتره
الصناديق هل يمكن وضع الامر على هذا النحو
بان هناك هذه المره ايضا صراع بين من
يوصفون بالمتشددين ومن يوصفون بال
الاصلاحيين على اساس ان من قال ان
رفسنجاني لم يترشح والسيد احمد خاتمي رجل
الدين احمد خاتمي ووعدت ان يوصف المتشدد
فكانها اشاره بان الصف المتشدد لا يرغب في
رفسنجاني اه هو اه اولا لا يمكن القول ان
الساحه السياسيه الايرانيه هي محصوره فقط
على الطيف الاصولي والطائف الاصلاحي
الساحه السياسيه الايرانيه فيها تنويعات
عديده وتيارات متعدده لكن نعم اه ما يحدث
الان هو اه يعني جبهه اصوليات تقف في وجه
رفسنجاني وهذا له اسبابه يعني له الاسباب
التاريخيه و له اسبابه اه الحاليه يعني اه
ال ال الوقوف ضد رفسنجاني ليس ك رفسنجاني
كشخص وانما رفسنجاني كتيار له اه مقاربات
سياسيه واقتصاديه واجتماعيه هذا التيار
يرى انها اه تتعارض مع الخطوط الرئيسيه
الكبرى للثوره الاسلاميه الايرانيه وهذا
التيار وهذا الموقف بدا يتكون من الجانب
منذ ان كان رفسنجاني رئيسا لايران في
فترتين يعني الاولى والثانيه ولذلك الموقف
من رفسنجاني نعم هو موقف يعني الجبهه هناك
داخل التيار الاصولي وليس كله لانه داخل
التيار الاصولي ايضا اه يعني هناك شخصيات
تقدم الدعم ل رفسنجاني اه لكن نعم هناك
كتله اصوليه لا يستهان بها في ايران لا
تريد رفسنجاني قويا في الحياه السياسيه
الايرانيه ولها موقف من ذلك طالبان المنصب
اه واضح ان التشعبات في المشهد الايراني
تلقي بظلالها على اه هذا المنصب نريد ان
نعرف بعد الفاصل ما هي المسارات المحتمله
بالرهانات القائمه داخل النظام الايراني
حول رئاسه مجلس خبراء القياده لنا عوده
بعد قليل نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
الم بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها نفى هاشمي
رفسنجاني عدم نيته الترشح لرئاسه مجلس
خبراء القياده في ايران كلما هذا المنصب
هو منصب مهم سيد شريعه مداري برايك كيف
يمكن ان تسير الامور في ضوء هذه التصريحات
المتضاربه وهذه ال الاشارات ال ال متداخله
اولا سيكون هناك اجتماع للمجلس وفق
الانظمه المتبعه في مجلس الخبراء طبعا
سيكون هناك اجتماع اه في اواخر فبراير او
اوائل مارس القادم يعني في العام المقبل
وسيتم هناك انتخاب الرئيس هناك عدد من
المرشحين كما اشرت سابقا اه السيد هاشمى
شاهرودى
وايضا هناك الشيخ اليزدي والشيخ الجنه
والشيخ واحد كرمان بالاضافه الى احتمال
ترشح الشيخ هاشمي رفسنجاني لكن بشكل عام
ينبغي ان نعلم بان هذا المجلس لم يبقى من
فتره في فتره ولايته او استمراره الا يعني
اقل من سنه ستكون هناك انتخابات وستنتهي
فتره هذا المجلس في الصيف القادم هذه
الرئاسه ستكون فقط
الفتره
المتبقيه القصيره من هذا المجلس اتصور بان
اه بانه سيكون هناك مرشح واحد اه من قبل
اه اه اه التيار الذي اه تيار الاغلبيه في
اه مجلس الخبراء بالاضافه الى انه يمكن ان
يترشح الشيخ هاشمي رفسنجاني التنافس قد
يكون اذا صح التعبير قد يكون بين اثنين
ليس اكثر
هل هل يمكن ان يتدخل المرشد في هذا
الموضوع خاصه وان هناك حديث عن نوع من
الود المفقود بين المرشد وبين رفسنجاني في
ضوء دعم رفسنجاني ل اه المرشح اه اه م
يراه من حسن موساوي في نعم في انتخابات
الرئاسه السابقه هذه الانتخابات لا يمكن
الحديث عن تدخل مباشر من المرشد لكن
تركيبه المجلس تعرف يعني تعرف توجهات
المرشد
والاولويات السياسيه والامنيه للمرشد جيدا
وبالتالي هي تاخذ ذلك بعين الاعتبار لكن
ايضا لا يمكن اسقاط اه ال الاهميه او
الحضور الذي يتمتع به رفسنجاني اه داخل اه
هذا المجلس يعني ليس هناك طرف واحد حتى
داخل هذا المجلس اه هذه الفتره فعلا ستكون
قصيره لان هناك انتخابات اه اظن في اه
شباط القادم ل انتخابات المجلس يعني هو
يجري كل ثمان سنوات وبالتالي هناك مجلس
خبراء جديد اهميته تنبع من ان هذا المجلس
هو المناطق دستوريا ب اه انتخاب اه المرشد
الاعلى للثوره الاسلاميه هو الوضع الصحي
ال اه الاخير للمرشد هذا الحديث عن اهميه
هذا اه ال ال المجلس ما اردت ان اقوله ان
اه هناك يعني هناك اه اهميه اعلاميه اهميه
سياسيه هناك رسائل من ترشيح رفسنجاني
اه حاليا يعني هناك رسائل
للخارج اكثر منها للداخل يعني عندما نقول
رفسنجاني فهذه رسائل الخارجيه لانه
رفسنجاني لديه اه رصيد من العلاقات مع
الخارج من العلاقات مع السعوديه من
العلاقات مع دول
وبالتالي اه قد يكون اه نوع من اه اعاده
رفسنجاني اه للساحه لايصال رسائل متعدده
تريد ايران يصل اه وايضا اه هذا مهم جدا
لروحاني نفسه روحاني يحتاج الى ان ينجز
اتفاقيه نهائيا بشان الملف النووي حضور
رفسنجاني في الساحه السياسيه الايرانيه
ايضا له تاثير بالدفع بالجهود التي يبذلها
فريق روحاني الخروج باتفاق على هذا الصعيد
اذا اردنا ان نعرف خارطه من يمكن ان يدفع
في اتجاه ان اه عوده اه اه الجاري ومن
يمكن ان يكون حريص على ابعاد كيف يمكن ان
نرى المشهد
فقط للتصحيح اولا لا يمكن تصنيف الشيخ
هاشمي رفسنجاني ضمن التيار الاصلاحي هو
فوق هذه الاطر هذا اولا ثانيا لا يمكن
القول
يعني من المؤكد انه لم يدعم من حسين موسوي
كان معارضا او كان يرجح انتخاب اي شخص غير
الرئيس السابق احمدي نجاد نعم لكن هل كان
يدعم ال حسين موسوي ابدا لم يدعم من حسين
موسوي ثالثا هو لم يكن بعيدا عن الساحه
السياسيه هو موجود في كل تفاصيل الساحه
السياسيه الايرانيه ولذلك لا يمكن ان نقول
بانه تم ابعاده حتى يعود مره اخرى على كل
حال انه ان كان من المرشحين لرئاسه المجلس
اه اتصور بانه سيكون له يعني اه الحظ في
الانتخاب قد يكون له نصف الاراء لكن من
المهم ان نفهم بان انتخاب رئيس مجلس
الخبراء اه يتم طبعا بالاغلبيه المطلقه
يجب ان يحصل ال اه مرشح على خمسين بالمائه
زائد واحد ولذلك اتصور بانهم والشخص الاخر
الذي يترشح طبعا اذا
يعني اه سيكون ستكون المنافسه يعني
ستكون الاصوات قريبه جدا من بعضها لا يمكن
التنبؤ لحد الان من انه يمكن العوده الى
رئاسه المجلس اولا ومات تتوقع سيد شريعه
مداري ان يحسم اه سيدي السيد رفسنجاني
امره في هذا الاتجاه او ذاك
اه انا اتصور بانه كان يقصد من هذا
التعبير الذي عبر به بعض الاشخاص الذين قد
يتم ترشيحهم او يترشحون هم انفسهم ولا
يقصد كل الذين تطرح اسمائهم
الترشح لذلك اتصور بانه لو تم اه ترشح
الاشخاص الذين يرتضي الشيخ هاشمي من الفني
لان يكونوا اه اه يكون هذا الشخص رئيسا
للمجلس سوف ينسحب من الترشح وبالنسبه اليك
سيدي انا اولا اريد ان اعلق على ان اه
رفسنجاني لم يدعم من انسان موسوي وهذا غير
صحيح لان الحمله الانتخابيه قد مولت من
قبل رفسنجاني انا اذكر كنت في طهران وكانت
اللافتات ال الانتخابيه الامير حسين
الموسوي اه تضع وتضع الصوره لتضع صوره
خاتمي على اليمين وصوره رفسنجاني على
اليسار و سوره ميروس ينمو سوى اه في الوسط
اما ان رفسنجاني ليس من التيار الاصلاحي
فهذا فيه الكثير من ال الكثير من الصحه
لكن ايضا هو اه يعني انضم الى هذا التيار
اصبح جزءا
هذا التيار من بعيد وليس بال عبر المشاركه
نعم اه بالنسبه ل رفسنجاني يجب ان يحسم
قراره سيعني ان الفتره المتبقيه اصلا لا
تعطي لا تعطي مجالا ل اه للمزيد من الوقت
لكن من الممكن ايضا ان يحدث كما حدث في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه ان يعلن رفسنجاني انه
يريد الترشح ثم ينسحب اه يعني اه
لسبب او لاخر ربما ينسحب لصالح اه شخصيه
ما وهذا في الساحه السياسيه الايرانيه اه
يعني معروف لكن هناك تقليد في مجلس
الخبراء اه عندهم تقليد ان الشخص لا يترشح
نفسه انهم لا يصوتون على شخص هو يتقدم
للمنصب التقليد القائم في المجلس ان يقوم
اناس بترشيح هذا الشخص وتزكيته اه لانه ال
وهذا ما تحدث عنه احمد خاتمي في مقابلته
مع قناه العالم اليوم هو كان يقول انه لا
يجوز ان يرشح احدهم نفسه كانه ايضا يرسل
رسائل سياسيه اه بشكل او باخر
فيها اشارت سيدي الى نوع من الاشارات
الداخل الايراني واشارات للخارج فيما
يتعلق بشخصيه رفسنجاني هل تعتقد بان هذه
الاشارات الخارجيه يمكن ان تلعب دور في
تشجيع السيد رفسنجاني او بالعكس نيه على
المضي قدما في الترشح
يا اخي اولا يجب ان نعلم بان هذا المجلس
له مهمه واحده وهو اختيار القائد وبعد
اختياره الرقابه على اداء القائد وعلى ان
يكون اه يستوفي الشروط اللازمه
مهمه واحده هي مهمه واحده صحيح ولكن مهمه
مهمه خطيره وكبيره يعني
نعم مهمه خطيره لكنه بعد اختيار اه القائد
يحق له ان فقط ان يدرس هل ان الشروط
المحدده للقائد هي مازالت متبقيه في
شخصيته اولا واذا كانت متبقيه لا يحق
لمجلس الخبراء ان يتدخل في تفاصيل اداء
قائد الثوره الاسلاميه لكن هذا معلوما فقط
مهمه المجلس هو ان يتحقق من بقاء الشروط
في القائد ولا يمكن له الاشراف او الرقابه
على اداء القائد لذلك لا علاقه له بكل
تفاصيل ال المؤسسات الدستوريه في ايران من
القياده الى كل المؤسسات الاخرى اه اتصور
بان هذا يجب ان يفهم اه جيدا
هذه المؤسسه تختلف عن هذا المجلس يختلف عن
المؤسس المجالس او
البرلمانات التقليديه الاخرى لذلك لا يمكن
لنا ان نقول بان القضيه ترتبط بالابعاد
الخارجيه او الداخليه او تفاصيل العلاقات
الخارجيه والدوليه لايران انما ترتبط
بالخيار الذي سيكون ضمن مجلس الخبراء انا
اتصور بان هاش هاشمي رفسنجاني من غير
الممكن ان ينسحب لصالح شخص اخر اذا ترشح
اما ان لا يترشح واما يبقى اه اه يعني اه
اه من المترشحين
الاخر متكافئه تقريبا اذا كان هذا هو
ترجيح كل نرى في نهايه البرنامج ترجيح
سيدي فيما يتعلق بالمال اه اه انا في ظني
ان اه ان ذلك يعني ترشيح رفسنجاني ياتي
ضمن ما قلت سابقا انه ضمن العوده السياسيه
ل رفسنجاني الى الساحه السياسيه الايرانيه
وليس صحيحا ان رفسنجاني بقي في الساحه
السياسيه الايرانيه في السنوات الاربعه
الاخيره من حكم نجاد
رفسنجاني كان من الممكن ان يقول انه كان
على حافه الجمهوريه الاسلاميه ولكن مع
مجيء روحاني روحاني علاقته القويه ب
رفسنجاني وفاء والتيار رفسنجاني عاد
رفسنجاني اه اه الى الساحه السياسيه
الايرانيه بقوه وايضا ما يدعم ذلك ان
رفسنجاني هو من التقارب مع امريكا شكرا لك
مدير باحثه في الشان الايراني مركز
الجزيره للدراسات شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
طهران الدكتور محمد مهدي شريعه مداري
الاكاديمي والخبير في العلاقات الدوليه
الايرانيه بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نصل الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه في امان الله
ام